remember MapQuest the good old days we
need to put pages upon pages of
directions that day before your road
trip and then on the day of your road
trip you'd finally reach a destination
after several wrong turns and gas
stations later you may have forgotten
about them but they are so second large
map company in North America only beaten
by Google Maps
despite that today they're simply just a
shell of their former selves in the late
1990s in the early 2000s they absolutely
dominated a map market back then math
questions a verb like Google would often
hear people saying I'm going to MapQuest
it but nowadays most people don't even
know what MapQuest
is or forgot about it so what happened
how does mapping giant become forgotten
in less than 20 years so here's a top
six reasons why MapQuest failed and
we're starting right now with number one
which is people had to stick it out
math question wasn't a stubborn company
that refused to change as technology
evolved they did launch nap and improve
their web service as well but the
problem was that their competitors Apple
maps and Google Maps came pre-installed
in the devices and while these services
may not have been better than MapQuest
at the beginning it was a lot more
convenient for users over the past 10
years mostly used her phones for
navigation and so even though there was
a MapQuest I have long as you put just
prefer to use the Apple Maps or Google
Maps or your prinstone instead of going
to App Store and downloading MapQuest
and this give Google Maps and Apple Maps
a lot more exposure and eventually
people forgot about MapQuest but people
download apps every single day and it
really isn't that big of a hassle so it
really wasn't that hard to seek out but
for people to want to seek it out it
must offer something a lot better than
the competition and the problem is that
not only it was MapQuest not better than
Google Maps and Apple Maps but I
actually started to have inferior
technology Google Heather Stellar's
preview where you could see Street as if
you were actually driving through them
an Apple Maps
rather intriguing 3d flyovers while
these 3d flowers didn't
do much to improve the navigating
experience they did garner a lot of
attention while all of this was taking
place
MapQuest still didn't even have
real-time traffic congestion monitoring
which could have actually been something
that separated them from the competition
for example if map course is a beloved
awkward the most reliable or the
shortest route then there definitely was
reason for people to seek it out over
Apple Maps or Google Maps but without
any key features like these it was plain
no reason for people to waste more
storage on another navigation app and
soon enough people pretty much
completely forgot about MapQuest and one
of the biggest reasons that MapQuest is
lacking in technology is that they lack
resources the whole company is only made
of a hundred employees and they don't
have that much capital to spend compared
to competitors Google sent out hundreds
of cars and spent millions dollars on
creating those Google Street view images
and no doubt apple also spent millions
in creating their own Maps MapQuest
doesn't even make their own Maps the
actually by Herman Dutch company called
TomTom which you guys are probably
familiar with furthermore Google can
spend millions eleazar marketing and fix
any issues very quickly at a time of the
day and there's only so much that
MapQuest can do with the hunter
employees during business hours this is
just an issue that any small company has
to face when competing with a much
larger competitor maybe MapQuest would
have never become as big as it did if
you're a bigger competitors from the
very beginning on top of this MapQuest
has more ads for example I just opened
up the math coach website and I was
greeted with five ads a Citibank ad in
the top a Comfort Inn Priceline and a
University of Arizona ad on the left
side and a Photoshop Lightroom ad on the
very bottom now this is not one of the
main reasons that people stopped using
math quest but still is impactful not
only was MapQuest not better than
competitors we had to deal with a lot
more ads while visiting their website if
you go over to Google Maps you don't see
any pop-up ads and this is a huge
problem from map
their competitors were able to offer a
map experience as much less cluttered
and the reason for this again post out
that MapQuest is a smaller company even
today MapQuest is a profitable company
and the issue
did they solely rely on the revenue from
these ads to make money they have some
other methods but this is your major
source for Google and Apple Maps is a
very small portion of your business and
they don't really need to make money
from it Google and Apple are even okay
with losing money in such sectors
because they're more concerned with
long-term profit and that you use all
their products and a little bit of money
right now they use their other huge
businesses like Adwords and YouTube for
Google and the iPhone sales for Apple to
compensate for these losses I'm not
saying Apple or Google is losing money
by making maps but what I am saying is
that they are opposed to losing money
and as a result they can always stay one
step ahead of smaller competitors like
MapQuest
in the end MapQuest is forced on
displaying these pop-up ads while Google
and Apple are not and this negatively
affects the user experience from
MapQuest and drives people away from
using it to make matters even worse not
with as much less public implementation
I'm not talking about the local bakery
that pins out their location on Google
Maps I'm talking about the over 1.1
million companies that pay Google to use
your maps and for hundreds of these
companies Google Maps is the core of
their business without it they really
couldn't do anything and as a result
they end up paying Google billions of
dollars you probably haven't thought
about this but think about the millions
of people use uber and lyft and uber
needs Yelp Airbnb and TripAdvisor what
dole these companies have in common they
all have millions of paying users and
use Google Maps at the center of their
business and while Google Maps is free
for the average is like you and me and
small companies you can bet that these
huge companies are paying through a lot
of money in order to use their Maps and
it's not just these market leaders that
have to pay googled user maps think
about all the big companies that need
maps to make money is very likely
most of them use Google Maps really the
only significant company that uses
MapQuest is Papa John's even Apple used
through Maps until 2012 as it is evident
Google Maps is a wide range of
implementation across a lot of huge
companies which brings in billions of
dollars of revenue for Google and this
key difference is really what is causing
math quest lagging every other segment
it's just a user experience and better
technology and finally you have the
negative stigma associated with MapQuest
my question is a small cartography
company that started in 1967 as a
subsidiary and it is often associated
with people who are older and are not as
good at using technology on top of this
people also offer an associate MapQuest
was a slow and annoying travel
experience even though MapQuest has
improved significantly nowadays when you
hear the word MapQuest
most people think of the time that they
got lost in the middle of nowhere and
they're happy they don't have to deal
with that anymore thanks to Google and
Apple Maps the problem is that most
people don't know how map course has
evolved today and they still associate
MapQuest with the all annoying travel
experience of the early 2000s and this
negative stigma associated with MapQuest
is one of the biggest reasons that
people moved on from MapQuest very
quickly and why the company is where
they're at today but as I said MapQuest
is still profitable and they're working
very hard to see if they can dominate
the market once again did you guys like
this video mr. Thapa like and consider
subscribing it's like some Mormon is
just like this one
until then I'm Ari I'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]